well and nobody cares has been part of
the attitude that has been projected
toward the steelers while various
players have complained about the delays
in their week 12 game from thursday all
the way until wednesday eric ebron who
was uh uh challenged when it comes to
securing the football on wednesday night
and that's putting it mildly he was on
the 17 weeks podcast that's a product of
uninterrupted available on sirius xm and
pandora here is ibron talking about what
ultimately becomes between wednesday
night against the ravens monday night
against washington and the following
sunday night against the bills playing
three games in a 12-day stretch here's
ebon on that
we put all of these stipulations in
place
everybody signed up and said okay this
is gonna be cool
nobody thought you would play three
games in 12 days i don't care about a
game check i'm sorry i know there's
people that don't make the amount of
money i do i know that
so what i'm sure they don't want to play
three games in 12 days either they much
rather you know lose a game check than
risk them not making a check the next
year because they're hurt you know what
i'm saying so it's a lot of stipulations
bro but this is sad this is really sad
okay when i first saw those quotes
i i wow oh this is jarring and he said
you know he doesn't care if he loses a
game check he knows he makes a lot more
money in the average person but they
wouldn't want to play three games in 12
days either and that became his mantra i
don't want to play three games in 12
days i don't want to play three games in
12 days i don't want to play three games
in 12 days
and then and and i wish that the
lightning bolt would have struck for me
without seeing someone else point it out
pretty much every team plays three games
in 12 days every single year
and the team that drafted eric ebron the
detroit lions every year plays a sunday
sunday thursday that's a 12 game stretch
and actually when you start crunching
the hours from kickoff to kickoff
assuming a 1 pm eastern start on that
first game and the traditional 12 30 p.m
eastern start on thanksgiving and we've
done the math and checked it twice it's
263 and a half hours from kickoff to
kickoff the steelers are going to have
268 and a half hours from kickoff to
kick off from wednesday late afternoon
ravens to sunday night
buffalo bills to cap it off so i don't i
look this is just
guy is upset and wants to complain about
anything even if it's factually
inaccurate he's just upset so let me
complain about the sun coming up in the
east whoever would have wanted that who
signed up for the sun coming up in the
east i mean that's basically what he's
complaining about because that is part
and parcel of life in the nfl three
games in 12 days he's done it every year
teams do it every year that's just the
way it is they just had their window
moved around a little bit
you know
i empathize with the steelers because
twice this year
basically at the last moment they've had
their schedule really messed with
um
they never really had a bye week
because of the tennessee thing in week
three and four uh back then
and obviously
this is totally an unpredictable
situation
now look the alternative
and and again
maybe some players
would say give me the alternative but
mike here's the alternative okay
that the pittsburgh steelers basically
would prepare for this game prepare
prepare prepare you know and then all of
a sudden on tuesday the game would be
called off and oh by the way you got to
play next sunday or
[Music]
i think they would have played
washington on sunday
so you either have that alternative you
play this week on wednesday or
you postpone the game and you play it on
january 10th which would mean
that you know the steelers essentially
would never have had a buy you know the
entire year they would have played all
the way until week 17 on january 3rd and
then
instead of being able to say
ah
okay finally we get our break
then they got to play a game that could
either mean something for home field in
the afc or
for the ravens either to be in or out of
the playoffs
and so the game means something
and then and only then would they get
their week off on the weekend of january
17th now again
maybe the majority of steelers would say
okay we'll take the week 18 game we'll
take playing on january 10th
but
in my opinion if i looked at all the
alternatives i'll say give me the
hardship now and give me the weekend off
knowing that i've got most of the week
off between january 4th and january 10th
i'd much rather have that
i think this just falls into the bucket
of people want to complain and they'll
complain about anything and everything
even if they aren't complaining about
the things they should be complaining
about i mean his ultimate complaint is
what you're saying they were forced to
wait and wonder when are they going to
play now in the interim peter from
monday tuesday into wednesday it's not
like mike tomlin was beating the hell
out of his players in practice it was a
light week that's one of the things that
guys like about short week football they
don't get overworked leading up to the
game because the coach understands
they're still recovering from the game
that was played so
i doubt that at any point between the
game at jacksonville and then ultimately
the game against the baltimore ravens on
wednesday night the steelers had a rough
and tough padded practice so it was an
unscheduled unexpected seat of the pants
mini buy they just never could mentally
come down because they were thinking all
right we're playing thursday and it's
like okay we're playing sunday okay then
it's we're playing tuesday then it's
okay we're playing wednesday and and
that you know
if you can articulate the complaint that
way that you're in this constant state
of limbo as to when you're going to play
and to get yourself ready to go it's not
easy and you're not sure and that's
frustrating
complain about that don't complain about
playing three games in 12 days when you
play three games in 12 days all the time
and i doubt that any of these guys would
have accepted what ebron suggested a
cancellation of the game don't get paid
for the game and then you're 15-0
splitting the difference between the 72
dolphins and the 2007 patriots my guess
is these steelers players want to go for
16-0 they're not going to be happy to
say well we're 15-0 and we canceled the
game because we didn't feel like getting
screwed around by the nfl so there that
that that'll show them uh no uh it's
just venting that's what it comes down
to steelers players venning and mike
tomlin probably not happy about it
because his attitude is we make no
excuses and we just move forward
right
yeah and you know tomlin's got the right
attitude
you know mike we've been talking about
this a lot during the course of this
season you could see this coming from a
mile away you could see it coming from
last may
that the nfl was going to be the freight
train rolling down the tracks they
didn't postpone free agency at the start
of the pandemic they didn't postpone the
draft a month and a half into the
pandemic they didn't postpone they they
had to
delay the start of training camp because
of work rules with the union but they
basically didn't postpone the start of
training camp either they cancelled 65
preseason games because of it all you
know which is a gigantic favor to the
players obviously you don't have to play
any preseason games now not to the 85th
player in training camp but to the
veteran players to the basic nfl pa rank
and file they didn't have to put their
bodies on the line in the preseason and
now you knew you obviously knew that
there are going to be some
inconveniences that are going to be
almost like split second inconveniences
that you can do absolutely nothing about
and i hate to say hey just sit back and
deal with it but just sit back and deal
with it
and i'm reluctant to make this point
because i feel like any time someone
does it easily comes off as a get off my
lawn type of a of a retort but at the
same time
every player did indeed have an
opportunity before training camp began
to say i'm not interested this year at
no financial penalty other than
obviously not being paid for the year
they would have received a stipend
instead but every player had a chance to
stand at the edge of the cliff and say
i'm not interested
in jumping i'm not going to do it this
year i don't want to do it and it's not
just i don't want to expose myself to
potentially being infected by the virus
i think anyone who would have gotten
good advice with the application of any
degree of foresight would have been told
things could get screwy through this
process there may be games that get
moved around there may be some
unintended consequences of trying to get
these games played
once you decide that you're jumping off
the cliff and trusting the parachute and
going wherever the wind may take you
that's what you're doing
so that's another reason why i hear
these complaints and i want to go all
the way back to july and say guys you
you may not have signed up specifically
for your thanksgiving game being delayed
to sunday and then to tuesday and then
to wednesday but you generally signed up
for a season of we don't know what's
going to happen next
yeah and that's one of the reasons why
when i hear things like this
i hear ben roethlisberger saying to
michelle tafoya after the game
uh some sarcastic thing about thanking
roger goodell or whatever that that line
was
when when he talked after the game it
was clear he's not happy i doubt the
steelers are happy either but
in the grand scheme of things a not only
does it do no good to complain but b
it really makes you sound a little bit
uh disconnected with the real world it
just does whether the players like it or
not i know they have a job to do and i
know it's tough in a week like this but
you're a little bit disconnected with
the real world when you complain about
the schedule that you have to play in a
football season
and if you are mad internalize it
refocus it and use it to fuel your path
to
the number one seed an undefeated seas
and whatever you just have to keep
winning because the kansas city chiefs
are still breathing down your necks at
10 and 1.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports